[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attends bien
ici
je veux des fruits de mer maman je veux des
fruits de mer maman je te dis à Broadway food
fish ftic viens me donner un 2 trois
la vie est juste une amende du côté soleil du
alors à
à tous
[Musique]
du temps sympa
tous très sympas J'aime
beaucoup le poisson quand je rentre du travail
le soir je reçois mon
préféré je reçois
monou quand je rentre du travail le soir je
reçois mon plat préféré
poisson mon plat préféré F  mon plat préféré
poisson
[Musique]
oh très
sympa Je suis comme un l d'aimer un poisson quand je
rentre du travail
je reçois mon plat préféré de tous les temps tout le temps
tout
le temps j'en veux mon St r c'est très sympa
[  Musique]
solo
[Musique]
le tout avec M stra c'est très sympa tout le temps
tout le temps tout
le temps parce que je veux SI Mama sh rice qui soit
très
gentil je coûte cher
aussi je peux M à propos du
poisson quand je viens du travail le
soir je reçois  mon
plat préféré mon plat préféré c'est le poisson ouais hein
ouais tu es sûr de ça
mon plat préféré c'est le
poisson ouais pourquoi pas toi
[Musique]
bien sûr sh R c'est très sympa très
sympa
c'est très
[Musique]
ni sh R c'est
très